nous va sans doute aller très vite
maintenant dans l'enlèvement du baron
empain
les policiers de la brigade anti gang et
de la brigade criminelle ont arrêté l'un
des ravisseurs et en ont abattu un autre
hier soir sur l'autoroute du sud au
moment où un représentant de la famille
en pin allait remettre la rançon
cet homme au moment où il s'est arrêté à
côté d'une borne téléphonique sur
l'autoroute du sud près de paris a vu
surgir des gangsters qui ont pris la
rançon sont montés dans ces voitures ont
fait quelques centaines de mètres se
sont arrêtés près d'autres complices et
ces derniers
constatant la présence de policiers dans
plusieurs voitures banalisées ont
immédiatement ouvert le feu sur les
hommes des commissaires leclerc et
broussard deux policiers de la brigade
anti gang ont été sérieusement blessés
la rançon a été récupérés intacts
elle se montait à 17 millions de francs
suisses environ 4 milliards de d'anciens
francs trois ravisseurs ont réussi à
prendre la fuite et je voulais dit l'un
d'entre eux a été tué et l'autre blessé
légèrement a été interrogé toute la nuit
au quai des orfèvres à paris et il
semble bien d'après les renseignements
que nous avons pu obtenir que les
policiers connaissent maintenant
beaucoup de choses dans l'enlèvement du
baron empain et qu'un dénouement devrait
intervenir rapidement
ceux qui ont enlevé le baron empain sont
très probablement identifiés dans leur
quasi totalité le baron empain est donc
toujours vivant on pense d'ailleurs que
les gangsters qui semble être des gens
du milieu vont probablement se disperser
pour échapper à la police et qu'ils ont
tout intérêt à libérer le baron empain
vivant afin de ne pas aggraver un
dossier déjà épais les ravisseurs risque
déjà la peine de mort mais il est
évident que si le baron enfin est
retrouvé vivant et toute l'expérience
judiciaire le pauvre les ravisseurs ont
une chance de sauver leur tête
mais revenons à la fusillade d'hier soir
sur l'autoroute du sud
éric gilbert c'est le rendez vous sur
l'autoroute du sud dans le sens province
paris
le négociateur devait arrêter la voiture
de la rançon un break r12 devant une
borne téléphonique
lorsqu'il arrivera vers 20h30 deux
bankster en kaboul l'éjecter rond du
véhicule ce qu'ils ne savent pas c'est
que de manteaux il ya eu l'ère 14 de la
brigade anti gang est derrière
fourgon peugeot également bourrés de
policiers la suite le commissaire
ottavioli la raconte
[Musique]
à ce moment là notre dispositif
d'intervention a pris en chasse cette
voiture qui d'ailleurs s'est arrêté
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
les ravisseurs ayant l'intention de
sortir la rançon par une porte du mur de
protection contre les bruits d'arcueil
qui donnait sur arcueil et lorsque cette
voiture a été entourée par notre
dispositif en réalité des individus qui
se trouvaient derrière la porte on est
ouvert le feu ce dispositif dispositif
qui a répliqué nous avons eu deux
inspecteurs blessés forte heureusement
légèrement est l'un des individus qui
étaient venus pendant un an 100 été tué
tandis que l'autre a été légèrement
blessé et est interrogé la fusillade en
fête a été d'une violence inouïe
tous les véhicules sont criblés de
balles en moins d'une minute on attirer
plusieurs centaines de projectiles
les gangsters en effet disposer d'un
véritable arsenal
[Musique]
je dois dire armés de fusils
mitrailleurs et de pistolets
automatiques et de grenades
on frémit à l'idée de ce qui aurait pu
se passer si c'est grenade avait explosé
sur l'autoroute mais les policiers
avaient ordre de s'opposer à tout
paiement de rançons et ils ont agi
autant qu'on sache en accord avec le
groupe
enfin il est difficile de savoir quelle
sera la conséquence de l'opération
mais le commissaire broussard de la
brigade antigang semblait
particulièrement confiant hier soir et
les enquêteurs pensent que le baron
enfin et toujours vivant les
négociations ne sont ne se sont engagées
que dans la mesure effectivement on le
groupe avait la conviction que le baron
et tant d autres éléments importants le
gangster arrêtait alain cayol a avoué sa
participation au rapt et son
interrogatoire pourrait bien constituer
un atout décisif pour les policiers
[Musique]